okay so this is in sinneth in Cindy a
bicycle dance India Incendia
why is it called and said view why is it
they do with fire fire and why is it
right and Cindy emit some incinerate in
Cindy a a yeah why is it called Incendia
so this is fire it has something to do
with fire young people why is it called
Incendia okay so this is this is ins
idiom uh people's is being a bitch again
um big shock why are we looking at
juries but right now I don't know what
the hell she's doing I don't think I do
not think peoples is being a bitch
how's she being a bitch okay what okay
if so you know if so you've already said
I'm not into you goes like this okay I
mean it all she did okay okay so I
learned it and pushed you know I keep
forgetting she's 18 and he's 13 fair
enough faith needs to move on from love
of God or or they need to just part ways
that is are you looking at what in see
him all right don't tell us what
Incendia
is I know like five you have priority
put in the comments and pulsed it while
the video is playing but now you just
look like fools by God okay let's get to
this stupid story okay so all right all
right fair enough the people's doesn't
really be a bad she's just trying to
turn and push Finn is being a crybaby
then like a million times
come on this is like a little kid
a lot of people's yeah I do hate her but
have you never had your ass dumped
before I move on I am pretty sure you
walled for quite a while
first cheers but spill there you go this
is Finn's ears oh he should be as big a
loser as I am no arguments there except
that I just need to get this out okay
so when they go and try to say hey okay
you're gonna do your thing you're gonna
go be people's whatever I'm gonna go
grab a corner here Jake says hey I'm
gonna go and find him a new loving
trance so he goes to this fire came a
twitch where the those dogs came from
and uh yeah thank you episode which is
got cool
I can't great two sides oh my god that
now is the kingdom look cool but all
these these people and these creatures
of the guards in there that they just
look fantastic
and it all looks like a place those dogs
would come from - I mean like just that
I don't mean like Oh fire yeah I mean
like the ant will design of them really
looks like it would come from the toys
and then these cool symbols and so sorry
I really like to design this place and
you got the fire king the voice came in
here with my wife in the room so okay so
anyway you gotta keep David there as the
king is very funny
Jake tries to act on behalf of Prince
Ben to a point where he finally makes a
fin version has to fight with himself
which I wasn't sure was intentional or
not to win over the king
but was very funny worth it actually
starts like show cake and so forth even
though it's all him I think it was
because what he's like uh it you know
anyone who feels like you can win can
take my daughter and you see Jake just
go like it even looks like wow because
so he didn't know that doing something
really mean and violent would win
because that's an evil thing but we just
thought he was showing Prince Finn this
being a brave but one thing he also
saying right here you know I've got a
lot of people's of it I mean why would
he say that if he was still trying to
win over Flame Princess
Jake is insane see that that's why I'm I
thought like you know he just kept he
got so uncharacteristic just have to
going to a point where he's sort of like
was talking with a but actually I think
that's a funny doing it but as we've
learned body or is that always prefer
wanted to have come back there's like
Pendleton ward to like show up at some
point I'm good
well I actually when we wrote the
episode no it was more about the workout
tapes something along everything was in
the workout tastes like that likes
something that no one else do to read
the stitching everything's in that's
wrong sorry back to the episode um so uh
it says do you know you can win my evil
daughter in Jake I don't know I didn't
want to be evil and she seems really
nice except when she's psychotic
like half the characters on the show
actually definitely most women on the
show um again I think it's like half the
characters uh and they go and she gets
really pissed off and goes after Jake
Finn Caesar is really pissed off because
she destroyed the pictures and
people's fireworks and stuff and but
when he sees what she looks like and how
she has sired by the soft side when
she's not psychotic
he's like I think I got a crutch and
something good
well he got it crushed after she slapped
him yes I guess he likes abuse well no
she gets the liquid fireworks rained out
which I think it's an awesome idea no
liquid fire that's cool it's just really
good nobody do that colored rain okay
colored rain is cool that's what it is
okay no but it's liquid fireworks should
be like uh mm yeah that's it okay yeah
well because she gets tough with it and
he uses if you notice he uses
Bubblegum's hair yeah I do I catch her
yeah and came in without bringing the
gum win and he was just doing the heroic
thing that he would normally do and then
ulsan she changes and he's like what are
you talking about I like you like it
wasn't like a romantic I like it was
like I like you I
yeah yeah yeah you're fine I have
nothing wrong with you
and that's one Elson boom he's like whoa
you're kind of hot
there was a one intended spark make a
gas joke cuz it'll be in Reverse gas
spark where you go she farts so could
this lead to a relationship and maybe
even a return of this character I know
yes because I accidentally saw a future
episode Atacama it's one where I think
like I don't ride these AG details I'm
not saying she's gigantic and she's like
trying to destroy a kingdom or something
fits trying to stop her something okay
that was the first episode with her so I
thought so I was aware of the character
beforehand hope I didn't know this was
the introduction I thought that was the
introduction so I think the next one is
the one you're talking about
oh well okay if I remember right I think
it's next okay we just give that one
no I love Flame Princess I do too I
think she's I don't remember a enough
rumor from the episode we're about to
see so I won't be able to talk I think
it's the next one okay I won't mean I
mean it's all hot to the touch one would
think it's about that but yes I mean
from what I saw it's like you know if
she was funny and everything I couldn't
get like a ton of a character but I sort
of liked what they were setting up I
really like this scene where she's like
you know well why do I don't like you
like me since I do like you and she
stops she blushes and just goes right
back into the me this IV that if they go
advantage I kind of remember they do
then yeah that can be a lot of fun um
but uh yeah so I thought this one's
pretty salad I love the I love moving
away from a romance that can't happen
now it's not even like you know any
people's is a jury it's like it's an age
thing which is like you know okay fair
enough I'm yet I think that it's Kailyn
javi it can work but you could clearly
see how it could not work as well and so
it's like I'm fine with that I can
totally see it now it's time to move on
and they are moving on they don't they
really are what about our saline it's
really like Jake and Marceline to know
Marceline and Finn would be fun but I'd
deep down I know they're not right for
each other which is like you know damn
it but I love it if Marceline and Finn
are right for each other
I can't quite see now how these two
would be right for each other but I
don't know enough about her yet we just
got introduced to her so uh so good work
um yeah but no but Marceline if it was
all I've been said this I was like okay
there's someone like people's is closer
to what he needs like someone more
subdued and thinks more rationally
because he's so wild and crazy and
outgoing and stuff you know but with
marceline it's just much more
entertaining and much more fun you know
so but I know that would resolve a lot
of our problems and so on and so forth
so yeah for me it's just more the
entertainment value but ya know if they
go with this friend I'm curious to see
where it goes so how about you
I think Flame Princess would be good for
him I think you know it has nothing to
do with this episode kind of but it's
kind of really weird though because I
feel like ever since they made bubblegum
13 and then brought her back to being 18
it makes more sense to me and watching
this episode after not seeing bubblegum
for a while it was like it really hit me
like yeah really she is too old for him
and it just kind of that whole scene
actually where he's trying to lay on her
lap and she's like Finn come on
seriously they did make that we all
heard it was perfect it made so much
sense and it was one of the very few
episodes where I actually really liked
bubblegum in this mmm I thought she was
great in it and it worked out perfect I
think it was great well I think for so
long - we didn't know she was 18 you
know I mean she could a lot of times
like she knew the sciency stuff but I
mean she in this world it's like
everything is so strange is so weird you
can't always gather how old somebody is
so I you know I think both you and I
thought she was kind of the same age as
him for a while beds 4 via oh she's 18
in it at first it just sort of seemed
like a number or just something it's
like oh just so they can't get together
or something but then it's like along
with what you said when she was 13 that
you turn 18 it's like okay now I can
really kind of see the difference now so
maybe then is that what I said last time
like when that actually happened well
okay what you guys weren't listening to
me just get rags which is getting to
what I was going to say in a moment here
which is actually would be interesting
to go back and watch those again to see
if this actually was the character we
saw the whole time or if they actually
did right or a little different because
if sometimes I remember her being like
especially goofy or especially weird and
I'm like that
sort of like you know around Finn's age
or something but maybe it could just be
how I remember it maybe looking back
maybe it's not that so it would be
interesting to Cal go back and look at
those eventually yeah I think so yeah so
how about you on this one
Lee has pretty much said everything I
did like to design one of the designs I
really liked was the flame King yeah um
what I really liked about him was in it
sounds bizarre but like his hands
because you had what looked like his
normal hands which are the little the
orange fire but then you've had his
actual hand outside of that which is the
flame or whatever around the actual fire
itself which I thought was a really neat
design because anytime you have like
some fire creature in the movie it's the
fire itself is the actual hands and I
like that it's the actual heat radiating
from the fire that's the actual hand oh
that was really cool I liked and
guessing it's a little nod to Ray
Harryhausen when Jake saves a little
fire guy from the robotic owls yeah it
kind of reminded the robotic owl
reminded me of I don't remember its damn
freaking name from Clash of the Titans
but that yeah I don't know if was
intentional or not with that I thought
was pretty cool and I will suggest on
that scene to you really felt it sound
strange but I mean like when he lifts
the leg in the what do you really feel
like the the time it takes and sort of
the weight of it and the angles and
stuff they got it I don't know you felt
the motion of that no that's another
look right before that when he's really
tall and he's walking because if you
look back at past ones when he's walking
like that he's just kind of going normal
speed and the modern thing in like most
movies is is when someone really tall is
walking it slows down like everything
seems to move in a slower pace and they
did that this time with Jake when he was
walking and then it's same thing with
lifting up the foot I think it's showing
trying to show more like how big he is
at this point in time plus one of my
favorite characters is Flame Princess
I do enjoy her I'd like I like the
character design of her and then I like
what you want ape and they all get
turned into a little bio that's where I
came from
that's the other thing too is when
everyone's whispering it's like hazing
awesome guess you see that cliche so
many times there's a movie I'm blanking
the baby was like this Billy Crystal
movie that nobody remembers but he his
dad was part of a group of people and
they also did their own little
contribution their own little cliche to
Hollywood you know and the fathers was
that he was in every movie like he was
always in the background he's always
next year and something you know that's
are his thing and everybody sort of
created this cliche for films they said
you know that guy over there he created
the crowd whisper because the crowd was
pretty says you know what
hey whoa they found them guilty and
that's in so many movies at half the
time it's like there's really nothing
these people would be talking about so I
love these satirise that so well that's
like just you hear the whispering but
then you hear the nonsense that they're
saying that really nobody would be
saying just really good lines overall
and it definitely is adding more to the
storyline because a lot of characters
kind of come and go
Flame Princess seems to be a bit more of
a consistence maybe in a sense like
there's gonna be more with her not to
give anything away but as you know but
it's like some of the other ones like
you they show up and you know they're
never gonna come back
they know it'll be for very brief one at
least with Flame Princess she can have
more of a meaning than what's there
well now so like that they kept her if
they kept her sort of engaged in this
thing and that whatever them so yeah
we're kind of like it looks cool but
you're like you know you know that's
kind of wave you really they're
containing her because she is so like
guys I hear what people whisper came
from well those the other good one when
it goes down there in the little guy's
name but what he does the whole chants
and everything I love how the tongue
goes up pointed but then he spits on him
is like oh I just did the chanted it up
and I Spit on you that's great because
you initially think that the spit is
part of the spell there's an actor he
spits that's kind of like one big effect
it he's like oh and I spit on you spits
on use it's already so yeah so I that
pursuit got to the touch segue no guys
are terrible at this stuff oh my god you
know what you know what we should have
some pie I like pie so do that was a
segue